[Music]
Dominic Toretto is a Gearhead adrenaline
junkie and family man who would wear his
heart on his sleeve if he had any what
he isn't is real we assembled experts in
the fields of law psychology and physics
to see how close to reality this
character comes this is what's wrong
with Dom Toretto
my name is Dr Drea tamendi and I'm a
clinical psychologist I'm Doug Ridley
and I'm a criminal defense attorney my
name is Dr Justin Christensen and I am a
research scientist at an aerospace
company if you know one thing about Dom
it's a steadfast commitment to family
even if they're not in any way related
to him absolutely familiar
is that psychologically honest family
members do not have to be blood
relatives for us to find genuine
connection and bonding and care and
compassion we can find family we can
feel family amongst people who are not
related to us and in fact a lot of
people do he puts his family first but
crime comes in a close second from the
moment we meet him he's stealing a truck
full of DVD players and we wondered come
on DVDs is it that big of a deal it's
like a few grand in today's dollars
right when they're dealing with theft
they change it based upon the value now
the question of when they stole it and
what was the value when they stole it
versus later is something I've tried to
argue I've gone up to a judge at the
bench with receipts from Kohl's saying
that well maybe before this was a
thousand dollars worth of merchandise
which makes it a more serious crime it
can be a felony but Kohl's had a 60 off
sale last week your honor and here's the
receipt and now it's only worth six
hundred dollars so we should be taking a
look at this
it doesn't get us very far Dom and the
family can't seem to stay out of trouble
like when he has to jump a card to save
his recently amnesiac girlfriend Letty
from a tank in the Canary Islands could
any of that really happen from a physics
standpoint you know when I looked at
that scene to me the the Gap there
wasn't tremendous maybe three or four
car cars long so let's call that 30 or
40 feet so actually if you're going 70
miles an hour and you just eject off
that bridge you can actually cover that
distant and about this is about a third
of a second so it's not unrealistic to
me that he could be ejected off the car
after he hits the rail and make it over
to the other side to grab her uh in in a
short amount of time if Dom survives he
certainly won't be happy but what role
does anger appear to play in Dom's
psyche anger is often a secondary
emotion to a primary one and the primary
motion is typically in the realm of
sadness loneliness feeling shame feeling
guilt because we feel so vulnerable with
those primary emotions what's easier to
show is anger and for Dom he is in a
culture where you can be
super extremely angry and show your
frustrations that way you can drive your
car off a cliff and I guess into space
you can beat somebody up senselessly I
think for Dom that is not necessarily A
manifestation of his true emotions it's
often the secondary emotion that he's
experiencing in order to process and
even even try to elicit what's deeper
inside I watched my dad burn to death
despite all his rage at the end of Fast
and Furious he's still just a dominant
cage luckily his friends break him out
on his way to the prison dumb didn't
appear to have planned the Escape or no
they were coming so is he even
committing a crime there I could
certainly try to argue that Dom was in
fear for his life from his friends that
were breaking him out of prison since I
can hardly say it with a straight face I
don't know that I would be able to say
it with a straight face to a judge as
well or to a prosecutor on the other
hand if if he could actually articulate
for real that he was worried one of them
put a gun to his head and said yeah you
are coming with us then it's a
kidnapping it's not a breakout anymore
it's moving someone against their will
by force let's say that they broke him
out of the bus and everyone kind of went
their separate ways if he was looking to
do the right thing in the eyes of the
law and the eyes of the jail and the
eyes of his term and all of that he
would have turned himself back in
immediately which again I can't say with
a straight face because I can't imagine
everybody ever doing that
between the rock and a hunt
a heart cool secret agent missions in
exchange for a clean slate when The Rock
makes that kind of a deal and it's the
rock so you gotta trust him of course
but he comes in and says that we'll wipe
the Slate clean again being the lawyer
in the room I would want all eyes dotted
and T's crossed so I would want to see
that in writing I would want to make
sure that it's approved by everyone at
the chain of command and there are times
where that level of assistance on
something that critical and that
important to national Safety or even
International safety
justifies giving someone that kind of a
clearance
but then again we probably wouldn't hear
about that very often because that's
something that they would probably keep
pretty quiet it's official
you're all free
one thing that's never happened before
is the karzan rope swing in fast nine
right surely that one isn't physically
possible you know again it's a little
hard to say but as they come to the
bottom as that rope pulls tight I mean
in general they're going to make sort of
like an arcing-like motion but you
certainly could imagine that the car
maybe bounces a little bit or has some
rotation down at the bottom does Dom go
through the windshield probably not at
first because it's attached to the front
of the car when that pulls tight you
know basically he's going to try and
gets slung to the back but after that
you know it's hard to say there's
probably a lot of tumbling going on as
they're you know swinging back up to the
the top of the cliff and then the other
question is does the does the Rope or
the cable hold so I did some some
research and it turns out that the the
strongest natural fiber ropes uh come
from this abaca plant out of the
Philippines and and that actually can
withstand uh you know breaking loads up
to like thirty thousand pounds so
um even in principle I think a natural
fiber rope could support that car as
it's swinging through the gorge now I
don't think that's a brand new natural
fiber rope that they've got on that Old
Bridge so again does it hold probably
not but but at least in principle I
think that one's possible
well that was new
wow and he pulls it off no wonder the
guy thinks he's Invincible the
experience of success really can make us
overconfident so the fact that Dom has
risked his life so many times repeatedly
over and over again that may give him a
false sense of invincibility and so he's
going to try things that other people
aren't going to try he's going to put
his life in danger he's going to
actually feel quite good at being the
only one who's going to do something
that's so reckless and so risky that he
has almost a reputation around that so
it can be an ego thing he's certainly
the only one who could have pulled off
the bank vault heist in Fast Five but if
it really happened could anyone have
pulled a safe that large through Rio
with a couple of muscle cars the only
thing we really have to consider here is
is that the mass or the weight of the
two cars versus the weight of the safe
so in the movie they quote uh the the
safe being 10 tons of top of the line
security so 10 tons is 20 000 pounds
it's pretty easy to look up the weight
of those two Chargers it's about eight
thousand pounds so in this case the
Vault just weighs too much the force of
friction between the Vault and the
ground is just larger than the force of
friction the tires can apply for those
two Chargers ah but they do say the cars
are modified side is there anything they
could do in a Brazilian auto shop to get
it strong enough to pull a vault well so
the thing we want to do is we want to
get more friction between the tires and
the road and actually there's a couple
things you could try so one you could
just try and make the cars heavier and
you know the cost of course is that
you're gonna you're gonna move a little
bit slower your acceleration will be
less but the other thing you could do is
they do make specialty street racing
tires that have coefficients of friction
that are about twice as large as your
standard street tires and if you use
those you're actually starting to get
into the ballpark where the force of
friction on the tires is about the same
as you might expect from that the Vault
and the ground so in that case you're
you know you probably could just start
dragging that Vault but but definitely
don't expect to go anywhere quickly
one thing Dom does do quickly is forgive
from Brian to Shaw to Jacob he won't go
more than a movie without converting his
mortal enemies to family members that's
weird right when we see Dom sort of
replace and forgive other people
in a way that it doesn't seem like he
has boundaries it really makes me wonder
how meaningful his attachments actually
are and so on the one hand it's a level
of self-agency and self-awareness that I
appreciate about Dom he finds um
something good in everybody he wants to
bring them into the family and that's
something that I think is really
endearing But ultimately I'm not sure
what he's trying to build here is he
does he just want people around him in
order to never feel alone is he trying
to constantly keep his mind busy and
distracted and even surrounded by people
who are likely to sabotage him just kind
of in order to to keep his mind off of
of the wound that he has he's sort of
just not managing his boundaries well
and that's me being kind that may
struggle managing his boundaries but
Earth's atmosphere isn't one of them how
realistic is it when Dom's buddies turn
a Pontiac Firebird into a spaceship what
would you actually need to do it
probably the best thing to do is look at
what like the space shuttle users or the
ISS uses and for those they actually use
multiple layers like three to four
layers of glass uh at least the middle
layer is usually like an inch thick so
that's kind of at least ballpark what
you'd be looking to to use but it
doesn't mean if you didn't use that that
it might not survive the the ascent and
at least some amount of time and space
and strapping a rocket to the back won't
melt everyone inside
um probably not the back of the rocket I
mean usually you know when we think
about heat we we think about either the
heat of re-entry uh maybe the heat of US
during Ascent or or when you're actually
in space and and you're looking at the
sun sun side facing
of the vehicle but so I don't think that
the heat from the rocket is going to be
an issue you're moving pretty fast and a
lot of that heat is being sort of left
transferred behind you and once it's up
in outer space is the car going to
withstand that that don't know pressure
I mean realistically a car is more or
less a big hunk of metal right and we
have lots of big hunks of metal orbiting
the Earth satellites
um so I think it survives fine and even
right Elon musk's Tesla Roadster went up
into 2018 I think and uh that's still
out there and that's fine so yeah I mean
it it survives if you're asking you know
can it keep humans alive for a
substantial amount of time the answer is
probably not so you're saying this space
car is somehow within the realm of
possibility it's hundreds if not
thousands of scientists engineers and
lots of vetting and lots of money so you
know in principle I think with enough
engineering and enough testing it's
possible
um you know do I think that a small
group of people you know with how much
time on their hands to sort this out can
do that I mean I guess I'll let you
decide impressive I know no
no that's not impressive unreal I feel
like I need a Corona speaking of which
why on Earth is Dom so into that beer
our memories can attach to smell and
taste and so when we smell something
that's familiar to us or or eat Foods or
have drinks that that remind us of a
person or experience or something in our
past that can be really visceral and we
may not even know that we're making that
connection that emotional connection in
our brains so there may be something to
the corona
foreign